Oh,
Richard Branson.
Well,
is there anything,
he doesn't do high school dropouts at
the age of 16 he started companies.
He's seen the wells and he has more
adventures than anyone could dream of in a
lifetime.
He's a creative personality and a
brilliant businessmen as well as being an
energetic charitable man
who has built a brand,
a recognizable around the world.
I Adams,
by the way,
he's also worth nearly $5 billion.
So how exactly did Branson
gets to where he is today?
Let's start at the
beginning of the 1950s in,
sorry.
England's Branson was born at the
eldest son of Edward and Eve Branson,
a lawyer and a flight attendance.
Though she was a flight attendant,
Eve Branson didn't sit
idly by on their days off.
She built a wooden trash cans and tissue
boxes selling them for extra money for
the family.
Watching his mother's success builds
Branson's admiration for entrepreneurs and
gave them an option for when
school just wasn't working out.
She was always supportive of him and was
even known to tell people he would one
day be prime minister of England.
His mother was also an influence on
Branson's active minds and his lifestyle
that have become so much a part
of his international brand today.
She didn't let her children watch TV.
Instead of pushing her son
and two daughters outside
to entertain themselves and
make themselves useful
though clearly brilliant.
Branson was not a successful students
who have dyslexia and growing up school.
That was difficult for him,
but this Lexia did not stop him and
now he credits it as a key part of his
formula for success.
If you have a learning disability,
you become a very good delegator because
you know what your weaknesses are and
you know what your strengths are and you
make sure that you find great people to
step in and deal with your weaknesses.
He moved through several
schools as a child,
eventually giving up on institutionalized
learning at the age of 16 but he did
not give up on achieving.
When he dropped out of school,
he already knew that being an entrepreneur
that was the right life for him.
He started out with an idea and it's
with an ultimate goal far beyond just
earning money.
From my very first day as an entrepreneur,
I felt the only mission worth pursuing
in business is to make people's lives
better.
His first venture as a teenage businessmen
who was publishing a magazine called
students.
I took me 16 years old with no input
or work for anyone but students.
Ranson was able to secure $8,000
in advertising for the magazines.
First issue,
this was 1966 and $8,000 was a lot more
money them so much in fact that Branson
didn't even have to sell the first issue.
Instead,
he gave away 50,000 copies,
building the brand's name,
Andy,
potentially loyal customer
base for future issues.
It was the first demonstration of a
brilliant business mind with an utterly
impressive talent for marketing students.
It continued in its original
form for three years,
but in 1969 Branson,
he felt the urge to make it even bigger
and to take it in a new direction.
Advertisements for records were a
large part of the magazine's revenue,
so Branson took records and the
magazine and put them together.
Essentially,
he spotted a gap in the
market for mail order record.
Sales,
his man order business when
it was Christians with a
name that we all know today
and that would be virgin,
but it wasn't actually Richard
Branson who came up with that name.
It was one of his first employees.
Though they were successful,
the name was perfect for the company.
As all of the young
people involved in this,
when you to business,
well that name,
it obviously stuck and to now it's come
to wrap present much more than just mail
order music though the
mail order business.
It was popular,
it wasn't making enough money to stay
afloat and Branson when he needed cash,
he decided that the best way to do that
was avoided giving the government of the
entire share of the taxes
that he actually owed.
You cannot with a scheme through which
he avoided reporting all of the records
that were sold in the UK falsifying the
numbers of those that were exported.
It sounded good and it
did bring in cash birth.
Well it was discovered and we actually
ended up in jail and having to pay over
$60,000 in fines.
This obstacle and a short time in jail
didn't slow him or his business ambitions
down though,
even with the tax fraud scandal,
it was only less than two years after
starting the man or the record business
that Branson was able to take yet another
leap in 1971 he opens an actual bricks
and mortar store in order to sell records.
Then it was only a year before he bought
himself a high in and was able to build
a recording studio in [inaudible].
Now that he had a studio,
the next logical step,
it was to start a record label.
So he looked around and ended up signing
an artist he thought would be okay,
but not likely to have overwhelming
success as no one else would take him on.
And so what was the name of
this newly created record label?
But of course it was a virgin records.
The label had success almost
immediately with its first artist,
Mike Oldfield staying on the chance with
the album tubular bells for nearly five
years.
To put this in perspective.
The record was on the charts as along as
it took from Branson to go from selling
records by mail to having
his own record label.
The success of Oldfield and Branson under
the upstart virgin ladle bit didn't go
unnoticed far from it.
Huge names like the sex pistols,
the rolling stones culture club,
Janet Jackson and Genesis.
They were all later signed onto the label.
Yeah,
drown the 1970s while Bronson was in his
twenties he focused on his ever-growing
music business,
but by 1984 he was again
itching to try something new,
so he took what seems like a pretty
large jump across industries.
He invested in a new airline business
before launching the full fledged airline
service.
Branson had realized the potential for
doing so when his own flights to the
British Virgin Islands was
canceled being wealthy.
They didn't have to wait around.
There's an APP or for the next
flight at the whim of the airlines,
he could charter his own plane.
So he did it,
but he didn't keep the
launch plan to himself.
Instead,
he charged the others.
He was supposed to be on his original
flight to the British Virgin Islands,
a smaller fee and they all flew together
on a chartered plane down to the island
is creative minds and business intuition.
They saw an opportunity here and Branson,
well he was ready to seize it.
Soon after his initial experimental
charter flight to the British Virgin
Islands,
he called up Boeing and ask what they had
for sale while they said that they had
a Boeing seven four seven available lands,
Branson bought it and this was the start
of his fleet of airplanes as he has
with the man or to record business.
Branson's saw a need and a way that he
could run a business better than others
who were currently doing so.
So Entry Richard Branson style.
They did just that.
We just made it that much more special
than the other airlines we were competing
with.
He says of what he achieved
with Virgin Atlantic Airways.
Long before it was the norm,
virgin was offering such luxuries as
individual TV screens to help people pass
the time on flights.
Now.
Initially virgin it operates is only
out of London's Gatwick Airport,
but by 1991 it had grown to the point
where it was given permission to fly out
of Heathrow British Airways.
Well,
they were not say pleased by this new
threats to their previously unchallenged
supremacy and they certainly did not sit
idly by while virgin kept gobbling off
the market show.
In 1993 virgin is accused of
British Airways of he's so cool.
Series of dirty tricks that ranged from
computer hacking to reliable following
the accusations,
British Airways,
they settled over at nearly $4 million
in legal fees and compensation.
Now you might be wondering,
well,
what did Branson do with the money
that he received in the settlements?
Well,
he didn't just stick it all
in his own bank accounts.
Instead he decided to share it with virgin
is employees now they the settlement.
It was a win for the company.
It didn't mean virgin and Branson were
completely successful and just had
nothing to worry about us.
On the contrary,
in fact,
Branson was unfortunately forced to sell
his music business in order to keep his
empire going.
Emi.
They bought virgin records in 1992 and
although it was a good business decision,
it was a tough personal
choice for Branson.
The music business,
it was Branson's baby,
it was his first venture and he was the
reason everything else he had built was
possible.
Over the years,
he's been very open about just how
difficult that sale was for him.
I mean,
you build something from scratch.
We had just signed Janet Jackson,
we had signed the rolling stones when
we sold it and I remember running down
Ladbroke grove tears streaming down
my face with a check for $1 billion.
Since the sale,
Virgin Airlines has
continued to grow brands,
so now today,
cell phone sector to his business and
then a space travel venture called a
virgin galactic.
500 people have bought tickets,
have an as yet unscheduled flight
into space with Virgin Galactic.
Overall,
Richard Branson owns 200 companies
linked to the virgin brands,
but well business,
it's not his only interest
and nor is it his own
Branson.
He could just sit
comfortably in his island,
resort home.
That's well,
he prefers to explore all corners of
the welds and to do so in ways far more
interesting and it's far more powerless
than in the comfort of a Virgin Atlantic
plane.
He's flashy than your average billionaire
with no qualms about risking his life
and the pursuit of adventure adventure
that also serves double duty as he can
beat the out of the
box marketing strategy.
He makes no distinction
between his professional lens,
personal endeavors,
simply aiming to enjoy life and it's
making a difference where he can.
I don't think of work as
work and to play as play.
It's all living well.
In 1985 Richard Branson made international
news when he tried to set a world
record for the fastest
crossing of the Atlantic.
They failed in totally spectacular fashion
as his boat capsized and he had to be
rescued by eight British
military helicopter.
Is that of this?
Do not be embarrassed by your failures.
Learn from them and start again as well.
Again in Branson's true form here,
absolutely.
Desk.
In 1986 he attempted to the
Atlantic crossing again,
but this time he succeeded
in spectacular fashion.
He broke the world record for
the crossing by over two hours.
But breaking this record,
well,
it wasn't enough for Branson.
He wanted more adventure and he also
wants to keep his name and the virgin his
name in the news.
It doesn't a water crossing,
but now we wanted to
move on to our airplanes.
They were not exciting enough,
so we opted to cross the Atlantic
in a hot air balloon and then,
I mean crossing the Atlantic,
it wasn't enough.
So he decided to cross the
Pacific in a hot air balloon.
Now it wasn't all purely for the pursuit
of adventure that he took on these hot
air balloon challenges actually truly
enjoy traveling by hot air balloon.
He says,
my favorite mode of transport
is hot air ballooning.
It's so graceful to be blown by the
winds to go where the wind takes you.
Now the balloon Branson
took on his first flight.
It was a record breaker in and of itself.
It was the size of a 21
looks story building and it
was built to fly to speed of
over 200 miles per hour.
It was simply the largest and the
fastest balloon ever constructed,
large and vast.
They didn't make that
balloon immune from danger.
The flights path was from the state of
Maine to islands as when the balloon
reached islands.
It didn't attach as it was supposed to.
Instead,
Branson and his crew found themselves
dipping into the freezing waters of the
Atlantic.
His crew jumped out of the balloon,
but Branson was forced to stay put after
the balloon rapidly lifted to 12,000
feet with him still in us terrified,
but able to remain calm.
Ranson navigated the balloon back down
towards the water and jumped into the
ocean.
When he saw her,
he was just a few dozen feet above its
surface and now let's move on to the
Pacific blue trip because
this wasn't much calmer.
They ran out of most of their fuel
partway through and they were dependent on
the jet stream to simply
push them forward.
Branson said,
I was facing almost certain death we
could have just slumped on the floor and
accepted our face or try
to fly the balloon into the
core of the jet stream and
finds the strongest winds you can find.
Stay awake for three days
and do everything you can
to avoid what on paper looks
like a sad ending Branson's crew.
Well,
they chose to stay away.
You can do what they could and
as they overcame that challenge,
they didn't break the
records they hope to,
but they did live to tell the town of
their adventure and that was all they
could have asked for it.
That,
okay,
School Amanda,
like Branson who devotes much of
his life to the pursuit of pleasure,
rent growing your business might seem to
be pretty full up on time commitments,
but for Branson,
business and success,
it's about much more than
just amassing wealth.
It's about helping people.
I never started out in
business to make money.
I wanted to create products that
made a difference in people's lives.
The same is true today in my opinion.
There's nothing quite
like the gift of giving.
When you see firsthand
the impacts it can have,
it becomes the best feeling in the world.
Branson has used not only his money,
but his brands in his new sobriety
to influence world leaders.
He and Peter Gabriel of the virgin records
span genesis talk to Nelson Mandela
or about their dream of having a group
of world leaders for them to work on the
pressing issues facing
the people of the world.
What,
what was the result of that?
Well,
that would be the group,
the elders,
a group of some of the world's
most respected former leaders,
including UN officials,
president Jimmy Carter and Desmond Tutu,
Branson.
He does provide funding for
the group and its initiatives,
but it was really his initial idea and
his willingness to Karen's have those
initial conversations that
really made this all possible.
And then we come to environmental issues,
which are one of Branson's
personal passions.
He's committed to hundreds of millions
of pounds to fighting global warming and
to even hosted a summit at his private
island in 2009 they might have the
question,
why does Richard Branson care about
preserving the earth and its beauty quite
some much?
Well,
like as creative beds,
Branson credits his childhood home and
the amount of time he spent playing
outside of this.
I was fortunate to have been brought up
in the countryside in a little cottage.
I suppose that the first 10 years of
my life were spent in the countryside,
biking,
climbing trees,
and didn't touch with nature.
I suppose that's where my
enough of nature started.
Overall,
he's worked with dozens
of charities in his life,
dedicating his time and his money to
the causes that he cares most about.
The United Nations has even
recognized his efforts,
giving him the citizen of the
world award in 2007 most recently,
Branson has thrown his charitable energy
towards helping the Caribbean islands
rebuild in the wake of Hurricane Irma
is destruction during the fall of 2017
with his home on Necker island
in the British Virgin Islands.
He has a personal interest in doing so,
but it's gone well beyond just
rebuilding his own luxurious home.
He spent time helping mobilize
rescue efforts and assisting with the
distribution of water and supplies,
as well as helping people find shelter.
Clearly,
Branson is not a man to stand idly by
when there is a need or opportunity.
Yeah.
In promoting the virgin brands and
promoting the courses he cares about.
Branson has become a highly recognizable
personality and a frequent guest on
news and other shows,
but he doesn't always stick to the
serious stuff he's made in the bond film.
Casino Royale and cement to
displace isn't nineties icon.
When he started on both
Baywatch and friends,
he was also featured in the iconic apple
think different towns alongside such
luminaries as John Lennon.
Gandy Einstein and public
[inaudible] Richard Branson.
He's not your typical uptake businessmen.
He's a creative luminary who was
impacted all the corners of business and
impacted many parts of the world
and that's what he aims to do.
Each day he wants to put the things he's
passionate about to work for himself
and for the world.
A passionate belief in your business
and personal objectives can make all the
difference between success and failure
if you aren't proud of what you're doing.
Why should anybody else there?
Amid everything Branson,
there's also found time to
marry and have children.
His first marriage was in the heyday of
virgin records when he went to Kristin
to Massey in 1972 that marriage blessed
him don't be seven years and the couple
of divorced in 1979 Branson had
already met his second wife Templeman.
By the time he and Tom Massey divorced
and his grandson admitted as much later
to piers Morgan,
he had a daughter with
Templeman in 1979 sadly,
I'm Charlie lived for only four days.
It wasn't until 10 years and two more
children later that Branson and Templeman
actually tied the knot.
Richard Branson.
He could have continued to struggle
through high school doing things he hated
and that he didn't care about.
He could have fought his way to becoming
a lawyer like his dad or settling into
a middle class office job in
London or the surrounding area.
He could have stuck it out,
but he listened to his instincts
and he went with his heart,
a drop house.
He could have fallen to the
bottom and struggled through life,
feeling sorry for himself,
for having a learning disability,
but it's passion and his personality
along with his mother's constant
encouragement propelled him forward.
Richard Branson drew on his creativity,
took risks and never
shied from a challenge.
Every time he failed you brushed
himself off and try it again.
He gives back to a wells that has given
him much and he continues to succeed as
a businessman and as
an admired personality.
Richard Branson once said that if
you want to stand out from the crowd,
give people a reason not to forget you.
Richard Branson.
Well,
he clearly follows his own advice and
this has led him to a successful and
passionate life.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and do not forget to subscribe,
but put our brand new biographies just
like this of Modern Day people like
Richard Branson or people from history.
Also some things on the
darker science serial killers.
We cover the gamut of people we think
would make a good buyer graphics videos.
Did you subscribed brand
new videos twice a week?
That's Mondays and Thursdays.
Also,
some of our older videos
over there on the right.
Most stuff that you can check
out right now and as always,
thank you for watching.
Yeah.